IT'S TIME FOR HASHTAG WARS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU GUYS A
HASHTAG AND I WANT YOU BUZZ IN
WITH AS MANY TWEETS AS POSSIBLE.
THIS HASHTAG IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
WHICH IS WHY I THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE A GOOD FIRST ONE TO DO ON OUR VERY FIRST SHOW.
JOHN HODGEMAN TAUGHT ME THIS ONE
MANY YEARS AGO.
#FILMPOOPS, #FILMPOOPS
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE ME AS MANY
MOVIES THAT SOUND LIKE POOPING.
FOR INSTANCE "OPERATION DUMBO
DROP."
"THE BROWN BUNNY" "THERE WILL BE BLOOD"
"SPAWN"
IT GOES ON AND ON FROM THERE.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
GO.
DOUG?
>> PRECIOUS BASED ON THE NOVEL
PUSH!
>> Chris: KUMAIL
>> SPLASH.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: NATASHA
>> LITTLE MISS SUNSHINE.
>> Chris: KUMAIL
>> ANACONDA.
>> Chris: POINTS!
NATASHA?
>> AMERICAN BEAUTY.
>> Chris: POINTS!
I'LL GIVE YOU THAT.
KUMAIL
>> CHILDREN OF THE CORN.
>> Chris: DEFINITELY GIVING YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
>>Chris: DOUG
>> UNSINKABLE MOLLY BROWN.
>> Chris: YES!
>>KUMAIL
>> REMAINS OF THE DAY.
>> Chris: DOUG
>> BRING IT ON!
>> Chris: VERY EXCITABLE DOUG.
KUMAIL
>> PEARL HARBOR.
>> Chris: CROWD WASN'T WITH YOU
ON THAT.
NO POINTS.
DOUG BENSON
>> GO!
>> Chris: POINTS!
KUMAIL
>> NUTTY PROFESSOR.
>> Chris: YES!
POINTS.
DOUG?
>> OVERNIGHT DELIVERY!
THE.
>> Chris: POINTS
KUMAIL?
>> CLOUDY WITH A CHANCE OF MEAT
BALLS.
>> Chris: POINTS!
KUMAIL?
>> GREEN MILE!
>> Chris: NO, SORRY, NO ONE